the way we originally got to that is
that first like we wanted to work on
a big mission that somehow involved
cyber security in it because we
understood that as a founder you need
also to focus on your strengths and
focus on your experience and
make sure that if you let's say form a
team
uh your team is going to be one of the
best in the world in doing what you do
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're going to be talking about
cyber security
for railroads yes trains
meet mickey schiefmann the co-founder
and cto of silas
which provides cybersecurity solutions
for the rail industry
mickey is a veteran leader in the
development of complex cyber security
projects with over 10 years of
experience in software engineering
research and management prior to
co-founding silas
miki served as an r d leader in the
cyber r d division of the israel defense
forces elite technological unit
he led teams awarded the israel defense
prize for exceptional technological
breakthroughs
and received high military honors for
extraordinary achievement and
exceptional contributions to national
security
mickey has been recognized as an expert
for smart mobility and cyber security by
the world economic forum
and he was featured on the forbes 30
under 30 list of 2020.
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
thank you michael thanks for having me
thank you for inviting me to the to the
amazing celeste offices here you're not
seeing what i'm saying but outside there
are
basically train tracks with mind the gap
and emergency exits and it's pretty cool
because
you're the cto of a company called silas
and you're doing cyber security for
for trains and railroads and i'm excited
to understand
how the hell you got to that segment and
then how you even thought about it
but i want to take you back first a
chess champion
candidate for me for master something
like that ranked top five in israel
how did you get into chess yeah wow it's
a long story uh so
when i was approximately 10 um they had
a chess class at school
and apparently i could choose between
archaeology and chess so somehow i got
to chess
uh what started as a hobby actually my
parents tried to teach me before but
they couldn't
they're russian-based parents always try
to teach you chess but uh depends on the
level that you get them but then
at school i started learning chess uh
and then i went to the local chess club
and then started playing and
uh ever since like since uh let's say
the
age of 10 to the age of 18 and found
myself like
in this in this hobby and started
playing in tournaments first as an
amateur and
actually also ended as an amateur but
like a candidate they missed the
candidate amateur
um just taught me a lot about about the
world and
it was actually my main hobby as a kid i
played a lot in tournaments i
learned what does it mean to be
competitive but also
how to be more patient how to think
about strategy and tactic things
and basically how to analyze different
situations i thought it
i think it taught me a lot uh it's not
it's something that you can only learn
when you have a game of like five hours
that you need to sit
next to a board and uh you're barely
like uh
you're barely standing just sitting and
thinking about the positions
and sometimes you play fast games
sometimes you play long games
and actually ever since i played chess i
still play it online i
even have a group of entrepreneurs
and people from the ecosystems investors
and so on that play with me and
we have some watson groups of startups
we organize tournaments so if you want
just ping me and
just join me i'm gonna ping you right
after this episode i would love to play
sure you get you're serving in an elite
unit in the idf
israel prize for security for national
security
yes so uh i was so so let's let's go
back so after
like finishing high school i went to
university it's something called
academic
academic reserve or to die in hebrew
and and then i was lucky enough to get
elected to
a unit called eight once basically
probably one of the only
interview sets i did in my life they
were quite hard and i'm not sure how i
got there but then
then i got there and uh i remember my
first day in the military and
understanding that i just finished a
computer science degree and i still
understand anything
um i was lucky enough to serve next to
an amazing set of people and learn a lot
during my military service um what they
learned
was like how to execute very complicated
product
projects under um constrained situations
that got in that way
i surfed next to very like a very smart
bunch of people
and which had very good practices on how
to work on
projects and how to work as a team and i
was lucky to have very good commanders
that taught me a lot about leadership
and so on things that i
still try to apply today in my in a
day-to-day basis
now being in a military setting working
sometimes on technologies and poems that
are
that are far beyond what we're seeing
you know in the default world
was that was that a contradiction was
that augmenting the fact that you're in
a military setting working on these
on on these amazing research projects i
think there is some advantage of working
in the military
uh on those projects because uh the
military has of course a lot of
resources
and uh and for example like you
in israel at least you get to serve next
to the smartest people over there
because
uh they don't need to they don't have
the challenges of the startup in terms
of recruiting
and so on they just get a lot of smart
people on there
um and and the challenges i've worked on
were feeling very meaningful
so they felt like very important
missions that we're working on
uh and that's what drive also drove
people to work extra hours and to work
over the
weekends and to work under very short
time frames and
uh and actually like the motto of our
unit was something like
uh um making the impossible possible or
something like that
and uh making the impossible possible
was actually like the real model over
there like you got very high level
problems that
most of the people immediately said like
it's impossible and then
you need somehow to break it down into
something that you can work on and
that's what we did and we were lucky
enough to get some great achievements
amazing and so some of the people that
you served with are also with you and
silas including your co-founder
and guava was also in your chain of
command right yes
yes so amir my co-founder and her ceo
uh and also like i'm very lucky to work
with him and
i was lucky as to work with him in my
military and was my commander in my
latest role
i was managing projects in the cyber
department and tamir was managing the
whole department
and we worked on cyber r d stuff and
once we finish the military service uh
we
understood wanna also work together in
the next chapter and that's how we got
the functionalist
amazing and how tell me the founding
story
how do you get to a position where we're
sitting
pretty much in the middle of railroad
tracks in the heart of tel aviv
and with the company doing cyber
security for this world
right that's uh that's a very long one
but i'll try to summarize it
so um the way we originally got to that
is that first like we wanted to work on
a big mission
that somehow involved cyber security in
it because we understood that
as a founder you need also to focus on
your strengths and focus on your
experience and
make sure that if you let's say form a
team
uh your team is going to be one of the
best in the world in doing what you do
and cyber security is an area in which
we both had a lot of experience from the
military service so we
understood that that's one of the key
topics that we can work on
and have some sort of initial competence
and then comes railways into the picture
so what
fascinated us about railways was that
railways
is actually in israel not many people
know about
but of course like in other countries
for example in europe it's
very involved um so
apparently in the we were back in 2017
uh looking in the world and most people
talked about autonomous vehicles and
things like that
uh and they were talking how how soon
we're gonna have
autonomous vehicles on the roads
um but then when we started analyzing a
transportation market we realized that
railways are already autonomous
countries and actually i visited
singapore in the same year or paris
and when you're in a metro in those
countries and you go to the
first cabin you don't see a driver so
how how how these things even
even drives uh and then we realized that
there is
there is something that drives it and
then we started to learn about those
technologies and of course we consulted
with a lot of industry experts which is
very important even if you think that we
understand things online by just reading
stuff
nothing can replace experience and uh
and up to today we still consult and we
see
and we hire like people who are domain
experts to make sure that we are
we have the right knowledge about the
domain so
back to railways so when we looked at
railways we understood there is a global
challenge
uh metros are all around the world uh
mainland trains
so you already have autonomous plans
somewhere in the world but you also have
trains that are driving very fast very
fast means like
350 kilometers per hour and even more
it sounds like the combination of those
two is a is a point of opportunity yeah
yeah and then when you understand that
the train drives in
350 kilometers per hour you think to
yourself like how does it even drive
that how the driver can even look at the
way to understand what's happening and
and and and the actual answer to that is
it does it doesn't need to
because he has systems that are in
charge of making sure that the train
will operate safely
uh and even if the driver for example
falls asleep in many
systems the train will break
automatically and
it will stop automatically uh and in
some systems the train will even
accelerate automatically
and and and when you understand that you
realize that there is some sort of
mechanism that
gives the train commands uh and that's
the wireless action mechanism so then
you think to yourself what is this
wireless mechanism how protected it is
and as a cyber person when you look at
such mechanisms when you understand
they're complex
and you look at traditional industry
you see that there's probably there's
probably a cyber gap up there and that's
what we understood back then
uh initially when we spoke to people
like most of them told us like
trains are operating already for 200
years i'm not sure if now the problem
starts but
uh but as people who coming from the
cyber domain and look at other critical
infrastructures and looked at
transportation market
we understood that trains are probably
like we will need to behave similarly
from the cyber perspective they need to
be secure
around the same time companies in the
railway business
also trans uh have started to be
targeted
by threat actors and since then like
many attacks have happened on companies
in this market
some of them are public some of them are
like private and
some of them are not being talked about
in the news so there's like a mix of
things because
in the end it's critical infrastructure
and uh uh
and and and those are very sensitive and
it's very important to make sure that
uh that the public still trusts it and
it has a very good reason to trust them
because
it's operable and it works very well but
at the same time companies understood
that they need to uplift the
level of security and that's what
happens today so
companies uh companies uh
are like since like our founding story
back in 2017
we see that like the industry realized
that cyber security is a big challenge
and we see it it's being addressed all
across the industry starting from the
manufacturer's side
to the end customer which is rarely
operators all of them
are starting to uplift their security
measures actually recently
maybe i'm not sure when this interview
will be published but there is a
standard
an official standard in europe that
that speaks about cyber security for
railways and it's basically its point of
reference for all railway companies on
how to operate for cyber security
it's actually funny because the standard
they started working on it like a few
months after we found
the company wow uh yes it's kind of
coincidence
and uh and we also see it all around the
world excels operates globally we work
in different territories i have a
question when you're starting
this company and you understand that
there's this gap you understand this
opportunity
you don't have a train to work it's like
you can go downstairs to the train
and and just test your code and to see
whether whether you're picking up on
something
and even if you do have a train
underneath your house it's a government
usually government-owned train you have
to get a set of clearances just to be
able to
to talk to the person who's in charge of
those trains how does a startup
get started that's a great question so
that's the first question which i got
asked a lot
also and i remember the first days uh
and how did we get
how did we get to the poll that the
point that we're now so
of course yeah we don't have train train
costs i think a few million
dollars uh that's like a typical train
uh
yeah in the next funding round then we
will probably build tracks in our office
to make sure that we can accommodate one
um all right so first what we did was
going to
stick with people from the industry and
those people are people that
are um domain experts they're working on
railway companies either in security or
operations and
we ask them about the problem just to
make sure that we even in the right
direction
we miss something which is very like
critical no one talks about it and
everyone implemented already security
and maybe
we couldn't miss anything when we
understood there is a challenge
uh our next like when i saw the next
there was a challenge like our next goal
was like to start developing some sort
of a product and our first product was
some sort of proof of concept that
operated based on simulations
so that's that's an important part to
understand also like a cyber person like
there is nothing like information
doesn't exist online you just need to
find the right way like
to get an access to it but like
everything is all there
and what we did initially was working
based on simulations
uh and those simulations helps us to
emulate like a real
environment and emulate how we can
attack such an environment
and then to show the potential prospects
how do we
like how does our product our newly
developed product can actually protect
such an environment from which specific
threats
that's what we did in the first step and
then the next step
uh we use this demo uh basically to get
like our first file
our first pilot was with a national
rally company in europe the big one
um and it was by showing this like
initial product and then they came to us
and they support
proposed us like to do a similar
similar uh exercise but on systems that
they're currently like implementing
and it helped us of course to get more
information and ever since like we
were capable based on the experience
that we gained in one project we could
uh we could uh accelerate our knowledge
and then to get
to the current level in which we're
basically operating tons of friendly
companies
uh around the world and we're capable of
protecting systems of different types in
the railway environment and different
vendors
uh and and and we actually don't need
like physical trains to do that we just
need the equipment that
actually like produces the communication
for example it produces the critical
commands and
uh and it could be nice to have a full
train that is doing that but it's
actually enough to start from less than
that
and that's how we work so it's similar
to the company that tries to work on
data but doesn't have the data
so you either need to develop it
yourself or gather it or like get an
access from someone who has it and
work on some sort of design partnership
or the pilot or something similar and
once you have that you can bootstrap
into
something which is more mature so you
know obviously
if we look around pogba when we look at
most cyber security companies
they usually don't go to these types of
solutions but a lot of them are
operating on cloud
on on those types of uh on those types
of threats and technologies you went
to an old industry realizing that it's
being digitalized and revolutionizing it
and when you're looking at the people
that are working with you do they
understand
you know this this mission and rather
because this is not a trivial thing
to to think you know independently right
yeah so
so we actually had the same like the
same thought ourselves
when we founded the company we could
decide to develop a point police
point solution to an industry which is
what much more mature
uh and try to basically solve a small
problem like in a bigger industry
or what we decided to do was to go to
this blue ocean
which is railways uh and define a
category basically that's what we're
doing
and and and um maybe like some
indication for the success of this
definition was that
ever like since then uh also competitors
joined this category
uh and we're happy with that um and
i think that what feels like people for
working in silos
is the fact that like you define the
category
as a category someone who defines a
category you actually get
more privileges than others because uh
you don't necessarily
need to beat the competition but also
like generate the best value on what
you're doing which is
not something which is trivial some some
people like have some reference in their
mind and they're saying
i just need to get better than that and
then i'm good but here you actually need
to sometimes
interview like a customer that starts
from nothing and build him like
the optimal solution for his challenge
um
and also like when you see the span of
fire like solution we're not
because it's railways it's actually like
very global uh
we can have customers in australia and
europe and north america and it's like
all of them like operating trains and
sometimes they speak different languages
some of them
like uh are are from different coming
from different cultures
uh we work with companies all across the
industry so it's not just like the end
customers but also the manufacturers
it's also like cyber security companies
who are working currently in the railway
domain just for enterprise and they're
partnering with them for
for like uh uplifting the entire
security level
um so and i think that that's what like
people here also see like at silas say
they're getting cranked on the mission
you can see it from the design of the
offices
like people know all the set of
customers that we have they know
the partners are they know where we
stand like we
believe in like a very high level of
transparency and everything
and we believe that when someone comes
to work with us he also needs to be
connected to the startup like
we also understand the business context
and the overall context of what we do
and how we
impact the real market globally not just
like understand what piece of code is
currently working on
100 okay so enough about about trains i
have
hours more questions to ask you about
this but i want to make sure to also ask
you a little bit about yourself
sure going back to not chess but your
childhood in general
what what really fascinated you i know
chess is one of them
what else fascinated you as a kid
whether it's a subject in school or
another passion hobby
so i think that like i didn't have like
one subject that fascinated me i of
course liked computers a lot and that's
why i chose it with a career
uh i liked all sorts of like more like
the awful certain scientific domains
math chemistry um
and others um i think
actually like i spent a lot of time
without this kind of chest that's what i
remember like
uh growing uh doing a lot um
but i was like a typical kid nothing too
special
there was nothing too special about me
and that like i was just uh
like i think so right
and what inspires you today so as you're
building stylus and as you're thinking
through
yes so so today inspires me like to
build
uh an input full company i wanna like
starting stylus was quite kind of
interesting because
most like cyber security entrepreneurs
when they
when they come out of israel they have
the advantage of
israel being widely appreciated in the
cyber security business
and and then like israeli solutions of
being widely accepted because of that
when you're coming to the railway
business
when we started with it apart from one
company i think
we haven't seen like any company that
was
very important the supply chain of the
railroad business like the
splashing of the railway business was uh
dominated by
companies the likes of uh alstom
siemens uh bombardier
um and uh and israel didn't have
actually like some representation in the
uh israel of course has israel railways
and now we're seeing behind us
uh the tel aviv red line which is uh
which is very exciting for me to see
like to have this line coming from my
office
um but we didn't see israel present
in this in in in this arena uh
actually two years ago we were awarded
an award by
uh the international railway
organization which combines
all the railway operators in the world
and they every year they pick
solutions that have contributed most to
the railway business
and we were we were selected in the
category
of safety so like security now is an
essential part of
fairly safe right it was something that
safety was taken for granted for a lot
of time and now security actually
becomes
integral part of it uh information it
was exciting
it was exciting because it was i think
the first time the israeli company won
such an award
i think we are one of the only israeli
companies that are actually
present in global reality projects in
the world
and i can give parts of them we are like
actually the core of those railway
projects we're in the core of trains
we're at the core of signaling systems
uh and taking it forward and making sure
that we are
able to generate like this meaningful
products that
support the railway industry globally
and doing it coming out of israel is i
think is a big mission
amazing and three words you would use to
describe yourself
right uh that's hard uh
three words um i think that things that
describe me
is like kind of optimistic i think i
think about challenges
but like always try to think about what
also the opportunities in everything
that we do
uh i'm trying to be a warm person and i
think the people that work with me honor
me they know that because
uh because it's very important for me
like first to work with people
uh and it's important to be it's
important to me to be accessible
so being warm is like one way of
doing it and i'm kind of curious i like
to learn a lot
i it's something that i didn't know as a
kid actually but i'm doing it more and
more now and i
like to learn about different uh
different
uh topics and when we started silos i
was like lucky enough to learn about
different industry
before like learning about railways and
when i started to learn about railways
and try
to learn every bit of it and i still
keep learning and there's a lot to learn
like
i need to basically
need to close the gap of 200 years to
understand what was developed in this
industry
um but i think those three words that
kind of describe me
like as a whole i mean
that's so amazing i love it and they
you know a huge pride you know both both
from israel
but i love this intersection of taking a
very sexy technology
that really wasn't around 10-15 years
ago and you know with the
security knowledge that we have now the
expertise gaining from the military this
is not
something that 20 years ago was even
relevant and now looking at these
age-old industries that are digitalized
and and having
players on the other side that are
finally willing and able to cooperate
and move forward winning or
you know granting awards to a cyber
security company in the railway industry
i think that's amazing and
thank you for taking the time to share
with me thank you very much